françois bonnardel bonsoir à vous
j'avais tout un défi vous ou un peu en
2018 on ne peut pas juste penser en
écouter le reportage on peut pas juste
penser élargir construire sans avoir
dans la tête la mobilité durable
ce n'est possible de construire des
largeurs aujourd'hui son ne pas devoir
réserver son impôt de covoiturage on ne
passe pas aux véhicules verts aux
autobus donc dans ce contexte comprendre
toutes les décisions que nous prendrons
dans les prochaines années pour
construire pour allonger l'a19 l'a50
l'a30 tous ceux de soins dans un
contexte de mobilité durable des
prochaines années parce que on peut voir
une opposition effectivement entre le
désir de votre patron que dit on a
entendu les québécois le réchauffement
climatique c'est important on a des
cibles à respecter pour les gaz à effet
de serre et de l'autre côté développé de
l'asfa de la sphère de l'asf at il pas
une contradiction entre les deux c'est
certain qu'au transport
utilisation de l'automobile est un
facteur indéniable pour ce qui est des
gaz à effet de serre c'est certain mais
notre côté vous comprendrez qu'avec le
harem qui qui prendra place dans l'apd
les prochaines années pour nous le
prolongement du rer e jusqu'à chambly
dans la portion au nord du côté de laval
on souhaite la mise en place le
prolongement de la ligne bleue
la ligne jaune srb pie-ix le boulevard
urbain pour ce qui est de notre-dame
donc ce sont des engagements qui sont
fermes pour nous le tramway dans l est
ah oui aura un équilibre nécessairement
entre ces futures routes agrandissement
élargissement mener ses hommes en
transport en commun pour moi un peu
capable d'améliorer la mobilité des gens
est ce que vous avez effectivement
promis la kek a promis que le rem allait
prendre de l'expansion
on va prendre quelques projets rapide
c'est prolongement de l'a 13 6 pour
qu'un prolongement de la trace de
corridors de l'a13 vous comprenez qui
est dans une zone agricole
alors c'est à l'étude on va regarder
comment on va voir comment vont mettre
ces deux là vont devra discuter que la
commission de la protection du
territoire agricole pour être capable
nécessairement de dézoner tous tes
propres capables de prolonger la trêve
donc dans un horizon de 10 ans on aime
son parcours exigeant donne un horizon
de 10 ans on souhaite tout les
engagements que nous avons pris à
hauteur de près de 10 milliards de
dollars vous comprendrez que dans tout
ça on va prioriser ses projets pour être
capable de mettre de l'avant tout ce que
nous avons annoncé donc l'a13 et l'a29
prolongement également à 19 secondes
c'est dans le programme québécois des
infrastructures comprendrait juste pour
lundi 19 on parle de trois voix de
chaque côté on parle de près 600
millions $ donc pour nous
longtemps voilà du côté de la transition
vers l'art je l'attends médailles dans
un contexte de mobilité aussi faut
penser aussi au futur rer e m qu'on veut
prolonger notre sont donc il y aura
beaucoup beaucoup à mettre sur la table
pour être capable de trouver un
équilibre dans tout seul mais par
exemple troisième la troisième de
troisième lien à québec
vous dites il va avoir de la
construction avant la fin de leur
premier mandat après des coupelles ce
que je sois le premier coup de pelle
pour le prolongement de l'a 13 vous
vous le souhaitez prématuré de vous dire
quand exactement parce que bon quand
même un horizon sur notre programme
québécois de l'info sur beaucoup de
monde qui nous écoutent sûrement ce soir
mais on va travailler fort pour être
capable de les mettre à l'étude
au delà de l'étude de maître une
planification par réalisation mais je me
permets de vous dire exactement castres
mais coûteuse voire élargissement de la
30e la gc la 20e rue si ça aussi c'est
du travail qu'on a que dans le programme
québécois des infrastructures vous
comprendrez tout ça pour nous c'est
important on accueille tout ce que tu
lises l'apprendre entre l'a20 et
ladislav de 82 qu'on parle maintenant
prolongement du rem ou si vous êtes
extrêmement important pour nous pour
rallonger de 22km cas chambly de 17 km
dans la portion de laval donc je
rencontre la caisse de dépôt dans les
prochains jours capable de mettre de
l'avant donc ces études qui vont nous
confirmer le coût additionnel d'un
prochaines années donc pour dans votre
esprit c'est vraiment deux leviers aussi
importants l'un que l'autre essayait de
calmer les automobilistes en prolongeant
ce qu'on peut mais sinon transports en
commun transport en commun transport en
commun ou si je n'ai pas la prétention
de vous dire qu'on va tout régler ce
jour là mais bon dans le programme
québécois des infos sociaux et 4,32
milliards qu'il y est attitré
directement au ministère des transports
les gens sable il y avait eu lui-même
tqt mis à mal dans les dernières années
+ présentement on a un déficit
d'entretien importante donc il faut
rapidement est capable de mettre de
l'argent comme on le fait en apprennent
à peu près trop 1.2 3.5 milliards pour
rénover nos infrastructures réparer nos
infrastructures et de mettre de l'avant
nos engagements dans tout ça alors
nécessairement sur une période de 10 ans
comprendrait qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup à faire avant nous j'ai atteint
2,10 à ce fait je crois que ça ne sera
pas très rapide tout cela s'est passé
vous comprendrez dans un dans un gain de
4-1 de tout médecin de l'avant si je
pouvais vous vous assurez ce soir car un
coup de pelle pour tous les projets
qu'on vous annonce et je le souhaite
maintenant on doit prioriser on doit
être capable justement vous messieurs le
millet est ce que vous en prioriser un
pendantla 13 plat 19 je veux pas aux
normes je veux pas je veux pas mettre en
opposition les deux vous dire ce que
l'on veut favoriser l'a13 en premier la
19 à 25 des projets qui sont qui seront
plus rapides certainement parce qu'ils
sont déjà dans la machine des transports
donc on va mettre de l'avant ceux qui
sont déjà étudiés
on va pousser rapidement tous les autres
parce qu'on veut répondre de nos
engagements
nous comme sur le volet mentionné m la
ligne rose c'est plus clair dans mon
esprit votre position vous dit on va
regarder ça mais en même temps je vous
dis tu ne sais pas notre priorité
donc ça ne fait pas partie des priorités
pour les dix prochaines années barco au
moyen long terme on le mentionnait un
premier ministre a mentionné pour nous
pour moi c'est le prolongement de la
ligne bleue c'est le prolongement de la
ligne jaune juste sur la rive sud de
montréal donc on va prioriser son va
prioriser drm ou si comme je le
mentionnais c'est un projet qui est
d'être 7 milliards de dollars qui 105
millions du kilomètre donc on a
plusieurs projets à mettre de l'avant
pour le transport en commun à montréal y
améliorer la mobilité mais là comme moi
comme montréal est gênante à la mairesse
me dire aujourd'hui je remette un
million de dollars dans ce bureau de
projet la sueur millions de la conquête
dans le fleuve si déjà le gouvernement
dit à long terme on n'y croit pas mais
je crois pas qu il le jette dans le
fleuve
donc c'était l'engagement de la mairesse
de mettre de l'avant la ligne rose
maintenant on va utiliser nécessairement
ccc donné que le bureau de projet de la
ville de montréal de mettre vos maîtres
votre déposée dans les prochaines années
les prochains mois nécessairement sur
son important pour nous pour être
capable d'évaluer la mobilité mais c'est
pas dans vos plans ctreq n'ont su
bonnardel on va se parler donc plus en
détails dont on va vous laisser arriver
de tous ces projets et la légende de la
grande grande région est réel attendre
beaucoup de ses promesses vous un but
tout à fait raison je sais très bien
merci merci monsieur bonnardel lausanne